you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 12
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and this is an introduction to
chess thinking the questions you ask of
yourself when playing a game maybe
you're not asking yourself any questions
when playing but you should the
questions you ask of yourself when
playing are more important in my opinion
than having the correct answers to the
questions having good answers to the
questions is something that will develop
you will improve upon this you're going
to make mistakes you're going to blunder
you're going to fall down in chess games
and you're going to rebound you're going
to get back up that's part of the
learning process you're going to make
mistakes having the correct answers
you're going to improve on those answers
with time with experience we want to
make certain that we at the very least
ask of ourselves the correct questions
what I'm trying to do in this video is
help build a foundation for you a
structured way to think this I'm just
scratching the surface here but having a
structured way to think through a chess
game what questions to ask of yourself
when your opponent makes them of what
are you thinking about when you're
considering a move on your own for your
side to the board you're thinking about
moving move X do you have a good reason
behind it what it what's purpose does it
serve okay we're going to have a look at
several examples here six well five
examples in a quick game at the end this
one being the first and I imagine if
you're what here watching this video
right now you're looking to improve your
game I'd encourage you to follow along
with these little pop quizzes and pause
the video when I say pause the video but
yeah these little pop quizzes I think
devoting some attention here to really
trying to focus in answer the questions
I'm throwing at you I think will improve
your game here I think it will be let's
say time well-spent
okay here's the first one for
example the last move here is e for my
question to you is what are you thinking
about when that move is played if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video see
what you can come up with what are what
is uh what is it that you are thinking
about when that move is played okay
efore let me say that the first question
you ought to ask of yourself when a move
is played is what is the move doing some
of you may already be asking yourself
that question that's great there might
be some something similar like what is
the threat that's another popular one
there might not always be a threat
that's why that's one of the reasons why
I prefer what is the move doing let's
have a look let's try and answer that
question and we're not always going to
be able again to come up with the
correct answers or all answers but that
is a question you should be asking of
yourself when your opponent makes a move
you can't just be so fixated on what it
is you want to do you need to focus you
need to give some consideration to what
it is your opponent's move is doing so
let's see what is the movie for doing
what might be some reasons behind it
well let's see if you said it opens the
door for the bishop great we know this
is a very good thing in the beginning to
get our pieces developed out and about
great additionally it's controlling D 5
and F 5 if you reference that as well
great is that as far as you went did you
just say to yourself opens the door for
the bishop controls these two squares
and that was it that was the end of your
thinking I'd like to suggest an
additional question to be asking of
yourself when a move is played not only
should you ask what is the move doing
but also ask of yourself
what is the move no longer doing hmm
well in order to answer that question we
have to compare and contrast now I know
this is this is tedious work here I'm
showing one move and I'm spending a lot
of attention here to answering a couple
questions but this these questions are
they apply in every position of every
game this is something that you need to
rehearse and I should also mention that
you know with the popularity online of
blitz chess and bullet chess in the
excitement that that brings it's very
tempting to want to play those time
controls a lot of fun but if you're
looking to improve I would encourage
much slower time controls where you
could really focus on this train of
thought that is having this a frame of
mind asking yourself these are questions
questions in trying to be as a
proficient as possible when you're
playing having having this structured
way of thinking is important what is the
move doing as mentioned boom boom boom
what is it no longer doing we need to
compare and contrast what was it doing
on e to that it no longer is doing when
it's on e for let's see from E to it was
controlling D 3 and F 3 it can no longer
control these squares that's another
thing we could say with the c4 move
additionally it can no longer control
these two squares either the only way it
was able to do that is if it played to
e3 but it lost its right to do that as
well four squares we can say are
weakened I should mention that with each
move in a chess game there is a strength
there is a likely strength and weakness
behind it some new squares will be
controlled or attacked some new squares
will be weakened this is evidenced by
the move efore pawn moves in particular
will always create some weakness
they'll no longer just due to their
nature just to the rules of the pond
just by the rules of the puns they
continue to move forward they could only
move forward so there's going to be
weaknesses they can never return you
can't go in reverse
d3 f3 or weakened d 4f 4 are weakened
okay so what is it doing controlling
these two squares opening a door for the
bishop what is it no longer doing
controlling these four squares there's a
lot we can say about a move in a chess
game and we're not even we're not even
at the point of considering what we want
to do we're just gathering some
information here knowing what weakness
is attached with our opponent's move may
be quite helpful to us may help us to
discover some interesting possibilities
recognizing the weakness that is left
behind let's say with each move that is
played we may be able to take advantage
of this we may be able to hit our
opponent where they are now weakened the
d4 square is one for an experienced
player they would see this as like their
eyes would immediately light up they see
this as a wonderful place for a piece
one day okay but the main thing here is
to ask those two questions what is the
move doing what is the move no longer
doing we're going to have a look at some
more examples here still applying the
same train of thought this being the
next where blacks last move is 94 if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what you are now thinking about okay
let's have a look what is it doing what
is it no longer doing some things to
note it's attacking the knight attacking
the pawn he's within checking distance
of the King I'm only looking at these
forward moves but he's certainly doing
some other things in Reverse so many
many things are happening with a piece
moving and
there's these eight squares he's in the
center a lot of possibilities a lot of
things to consider I'd like to also
mention what is he no longer doing well
to compare and contrast he's no longer
controlling ei guarding h7 no longer
hits h5 g4 d7 why am i drawing some
attention so much attention to these
this idea of what the move is no longer
doing well you may be missing
opportunities for example on the white
side you may do a move like Knight here
just moving the knight in a different
position and not seeing a way to take
advantage of a weakness behind Black's
last move this d7 square in particular
it's no longer all a follow-up question
no we're just gathering information here
a follow-up question when your opponent
makes a move is is there a way to take
advantage of the weakness that has been
left behind by my opponent's move this
is an example of well yes you can
in this particular case take advantage
of the weakness that has been left
behind he's no longer there to control
d7 we can in fact play Knight to d7 with
the fork we're going to win some
material if we were not asking ourselves
that question maybe a move like this
would be a bit more difficult to see
okay what is the move doing what is the
move no longer doing let's have a look
at another example right here where
blacks last move was to develop the
bishop what is it doing what is it no
longer doing attacks the knight it
develops what is it no longer doing I'm
these aren't the only things but just
kind of a fast-forwarding a little bit
what is it doing noting a couple things
here attacking the knight it's not--
what is it no longer doing it's no
longer controlling b7 mmm this might cap
I want to this
may capture our attention or should
capture our attention because follow up
moves of let's say bringing the Queen
out developing with an attack mmm these
start to be interesting possibilities
not saying right away it's best maybe
you do something like this
attack the bishop and then make a move
like this but noticing the weakness that
has been left behind maybe that's a good
way to react to your opponent's move we
need to ask what is the move doing what
is it move no longer doing the weakness
that has been left behind in this case
that b7 square is now weakened can we
take advantage of this this might be a
way to do that let's have a look at
another example where blacks last move
is d4 what is the move doing well he's
attacking the knight
what is the pawn no longer doing well
he's no longer all a 4 B 4 additionally
there is you know it's not just about
what the pawn is doing there's there's
other things happening you know this
efore square I said is weakened but also
it opens up now a new it opens up
something more for white how might you
this is another important part here how
might you reply to your opponent's move
I've been sharing this question what is
the move doing suppose one of the moves
your opponent makes is a threat where do
you go from there suppose this is the
situation you're in your opponent makes
a move and there is a threat here a
threat to win some material pawn takes
Knight how are you replying how are you
responding to situations like these
where you're under fire all of a sudden
your opponent is throwing a threat at
you what runs through your mind I think
what you should do or should be asking
yourself is can I ignore the threat
for how to react think uh should I react
can I ignore it is this really so big a
threat can I do something that's even
stronger is maybe a better frame of mind
to be and before you think about how to
respond to your opponents threats maybe
you should think you know what maybe
there's a way maybe there's a way that I
can throw an even stronger punch in my
opponent this is a pun that's attacking
at night maybe there's a way that we can
attack our opponents King there's a
certain list that we can go through the
most forcing moves are the ones that
threaten checkmate in one the next would
let's say be ones that simply deliver
check to the to the enemy King attacking
the Queen attacking the rook that type
of progression is one that you can go
through they will likely be stronger and
it will be your opponent who's probably
having to react all of a sudden to your
reply in this case you're upon your
opponent's pawn is attacking the knight
here should you react is there a way
that you could do something stronger in
this particular case there is
let's take note that this pawn is
attacking the knight but he's weakening
these squares and additionally opening
up a diagonal for the White Queen this
is a terrible move as it turns out but
if you're too fixated on reacting to
your opponent's threats you don't
necessarily always have to do that there
may be something better a stronger move
you can throw back at your opponent the
move Queen takes pawn is hitting black
with the fork and yeah it's just big
trouble here you get the rook and big
problems for team black white is white
is winning here so let's have a look at
just a couple
more examples here still playing off of
this idea right here which is to say
what is the move
what is the move doing okay we see that
it is attacking the knight what is it no
longer doing it's no longer controlling
these squares okay this in this
particular case there is a threat you
need to be very cautious now in that
previous example I showed an instance
where we can't ignore our opponents
threat and come up with something strong
or something more forceful you need to
be careful here too if you are going to
ignore your opponent's threats if you do
a move like this let's just say Bishop
to b4 this is an instance of you
throwing a threat that really isn't a
good one
because of how white can reply you need
to be very delicate if you are going to
ignore your opponent's threats in other
words and generate a threat of your own
in this particular case if you're
inserting this check first ignoring the
threat on your knight notice that in
this particular case white can reply to
your threat of check by simply blocking
and attacking what is now another piece
so all of a sudden in a situation like
this where black things he could ignore
this threat and instead insert this
check well now there's two issues that
black has to deal with and some material
will be lost on the next move you can
only save one of these two pieces in
this particular case so you need to be
very delicate as what I'm getting at
it's still the correct frame of mind to
be in which is to say if you are under
fire for your opponent is generating a
threat you may be able to simply ignore
it and generate a tea and even stronger
threat so at least consider at least
consider throwing a stronger threat back
at your opponent before you react okay
you don't necessarily have to react all
right as a close to
to this video I'd like to show a quick
game here on that is under 20 moves by
the greatest attacking player as well
many would have him pegged as the
greatest attacking player mikhail tall
he is playing on the white side against
salnikov this is a short game and here's
how it played out I want to get to this
one particular position right here f6
okay f6 let's see what is it doing what
is it no longer doing these same
questions all right well we see that the
e5 pawn is under fire that is attacked
g5 is defended the weakness that has
been left behind with that last move Yi
6 and g6
we may also start to view it as well
this opens a diagonal towards the enemy
King the reply that tall comes up with
is Knight to g5 and let me first point
out that this is not the best move and
in fact as it turns out it's a bad move
white doesn't are extremely black does
not reply eventually well enough to this
idea that tal has with Knight to g5 but
I wanted to highlight at least this
particular game this particular move
Knight g5 because if tall was not asking
of himself
what is the move no longer doing a move
like this really doesn't it doesn't
really enter your thought process I mean
I could see so many players being
fixated on the e5 square and that's the
first thing that really comes to mind it
came to mind for me the pressure on this
square but again having some devoting
some attention to what the move is no
longer doing is is very important it's
weakening tall the attacking player tall
here he sees the weakness
maybe even before he even sees the the
the strength behind the enemies last
move blacks last move here he's trying
to find a way to exploit the weakness
that has been left behind there are gaps
there's strength again there's strengths
and weaknesses with your opponent's
moves he's trying to capitalize on the
weaknesses that have been left behind
with blacks last move the move Knight g5
was played the knight is taken the Queen
comes out delivers a check blocks chop
chop and this is where we now have a
mistake by black after the move Bishop
to h6 this is not a good move a better
move is to take here but I want to just
fast-forward to this point here and go
with what was played in the game Bishop
h6 Bishop takes g5 Bishop takes Bishop
and now what would you do in this
position as Y if you'd like to pause the
video see what you come up with okay of
course Queen takes Bishop right because
it takes a piece and delivers check not
quite the last note I want to make here
is a famous quote by Emmanuel Lasker
when you see a good move look for a
better one this is very tempting to just
want to take the bishop and then you
know do so and give check but in this
case you can actually deliberate a mate
in one King to e8 is only only move and
then Knight d6 is checkmate that's the
last quick little tip when you see a
good move it's a very common well I
should say a very popular phrase by
Emmanuel asker when you see a good move
look for a better one I know I'm
throwing a lot of stuff at you here and
this is supposed to be just an
introduction I have no idea how long
it's been going but having a structured
way of thinking is most important these
two questions what is the move doing
what is the move no longer doing know
that with each move that is played there
will be a strength and weakness you
could when it's your turn to move I know
I've been applying it
I've been sharing examples where the
opponent makes a move but when you're
considering one of your own moves
consider not only what it is doing but
what gaps you're maybe leaving behind
what weaknesses are you leaving behind
that your opponent may be able to take
advantage of in one other thing I know
there may be the temptation to try and
think many moves ahead in a chess game
I'd like to you I don't think that that
is so important you really need to focus
it's going to sound a little bit weird
but you really need to focus on being
proficient with thinking just one move
ahead with really identifying what the
moves are doing don't try to get too
ahead of yourself with calculating two
three moves that's it's a it's really a
bit of a stretch you really need to
focus on being proficient with correctly
identifying what the move is doing what
the move is no longer doing slow you're
thinking down I suggest playing some
slower time control games to really
train this way of thinking to really get
you in this good frame of mind when
playing and this is I think a an
excellent start to you developing as a
chess player I think these are good tips
good questions to be asking of yourself
common questions but important questions
to be rehearsing when you're playing in
a chess game so I'm going to wrap things
up here like I normally do with saying I
hope you got something out of this video
feel free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below and we'll see
what's in store in this series this
playlist with video 13 so that's all for
now again I hope you got something out
of it take care bye
you